ما ان عاد الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
من اندونيسيا حتى دوره الانفجارات بالعراق
وسوريا مدمره نحو 90 هدفا في قواعد
للمسلحين الاكراد يوم الحساب اتى بكلمتين
وصوره لمقاتله تقلع لتنفيذ غاره ليليه
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع التركيه عن شنها عمليه
المخلب السيف وبالفعل قصفت الطائره
الحربيه بخمسه وعشرين ضربه قنديل وسوس
وهاكرك في العراق وكباني وتل رفعه وذراك
في شمال سوريا
صدام
وانفاق ومستودعات للمسلحين نسفت ولم يكن
هذا الدمار الا جزء من ضمان امني 85 مليون
من الاتراك على حد تعبيره
حسبناهم ولن نتوانا عن حسابهم في كل مره
يمس بها استقرار بلادنا هكذا يتابع اثار
قوله لتاخذ تركيا بثارها من مقاتلنا اكراد
ينتمون لحزب العمال الكردستاني غارات قتلت
واصابه العشرات من المدنيين عدا عن فقدان
اخرين بين تلك الانقاذ بحسب ما افاد به
المرصد السوري اما اداره شمال وشرق سوريا
بعد ان اتخذت انقره من حادثه اسطنبول
ذريعه للجن عملياتها بدوره حزب العمال
للكردستاني اتهم تركيا بامتلاك خطوط غامضه
واظهار كوباني كهدف تلك المدينه التي تمثل
رمزا لحمايه الاكراد من تنظيم داعش منذ
عكرت اجوائها الطائره التركيه مره رائعه
بدات بعمليه درع الفرات في 2016 ثم بغصن
الزيتون في العام الذي يليه الى نبع
السلام
قبل ثلاث سنوات
اسراء الصغير العربيه